bonsoir nouveau numéro du 7-8 politique
sur tv fil 78 cette semaine je reçois
notamment ripaille au maire divers
droite de coignières depuis 1986 il
vient d'annoncer sa démission il nous
expliquera tout à l'heure pourquoi c'est
un homme engagé il vient de publier la
force de la conviction un maire et ses
combats aux éditions de l'archipel
mais tout d'abord cette information
concernant le parti socialiste et le
député de la 11e circonscription benoît
hamon avec son courant un monde d'avancé
il propose en vue du congrès du parti
présidentiel au mois de juin une
contribution sévère contre la politique
menée au niveau national extrait de
cette contribution vente et en chine les
possibilités de licenciés en france pour
attirer quelques investisseurs
supplémentaires sonne comme une
soumission inacceptable à la course
mondiale au moins disant social que l'on
croyait jusqu'ici réservées à nos
adversaires politiques une réaction vous
l'avez compris au dernier déplacement du
premier ministre pourquoi de tels propos
la réponse de l'ex ministre fondeurs ont
gouverné le front national ne cesse de
monter il ne cesse de monter parce que
beaucoup de français entendent parler de
république mais en font pas beaucoup la
expérience que c'est faire l'expérience
de la république c'est
avoir le sentiment que les
inégalité recul que
l'école fonctionne mieux
e
qu'on est rémunéré à la hauteur du
travail que l'on fait que l'on peut
progresser c'est quand vous avez 20 ans
et l'idée que vous êtes condamné a
finalement rester toujours au même
niveau en termes de rémunération de
place dans la société c'est comme
désespérant et la république en théorie
elle propose
une espérance contraire à ce live ben
voila moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
rôle du parti socialiste il est poussé
le gouvernement d'aider le gouvernement
à faire en sorte que les français
fassent l'expérience de la république
plus souvent donc de l'égalité de la
fraternité de la liberté réelle
plutôt que le contraire première invitée
à présenter cette édition cyril
fonvieille bonsoir mes soirées vous êtes
le responsable dans les yvelines de sens
comme un sens commun c'est un mouvement
qui est né au sein de l'ump par des
anciens quelques-uns en tout cas de la
manif pour tous et qui entend peser sur
les choix de la formation politique il
ya eu d'ailleurs mardi dernier un
meeting qui a été organisée à bois
d'arcy où les fondateurs du mouvement
étaient présents aujourd'hui que
représente sens commun est ce que vous
vous êtes devenu un mouvement
incontournable au sein de l'ump on va
tout de même rappeler que pendant la
campagne pour la présidence de l'ump
vous êtes l'un des sommes pouvant le
seul mouvement avoir réussi à réunir les
trois candidats à ce moment là tu te
fais pendant le pendant le mois de
novembre on avait organisé un meeting
autour du manifeste qu'on avait lancé la
droite que nous voulons qu'ils
entendaient remettre vraiment les idées
au coeur du débat avec ce constat qu'on
essaye de faire partager le plus
largement possible depuis la création de
sens commun qu'il ya un peu plus d'un an
que à partir du moment où on oublie de
s'intéresser aux idées de se poser les
bonnes questions finalement on finit par
s'intéresser qu'à des querelles de
personnes et les querelles d'ego et ça
donne un spectacle assez triste on l'a
vu à l'ump avec la bataille entre
jean françois copé et françois fillon
et même depuis on voit que les querelles
sont pas complètement éteinte tout ça
c'est très dommageable parce que
finalement le pays a besoin qu'on
réfléchisse qu'on est con qu'on fasse
avec sérieux on n'est pas là pour des
question d'ambition personnelle donc je
crois que ça c'est important de le
souligner notre volonté aujourd'hui
c'est de porter un renouveau des idées à
renouveau des pratiques politiques ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens à
l'intérieur de l'ump voilà c'est le pari
que fait sens comment et quand vous
parlez des idées justement j'évoquais la
manif pour tous c'est à dire que vous
vous inscrivez très clairement dans
cette lignée là c'est alors c'est le
prolongement politique de la manif pour
tous non ça ne rime t s'est souvent vu
comme ça je trouve que c'est très
réducteur parce que sens commun
s'exprime sur tout un tas de sujets pas
uniquement les sujets sociétaux si vous
voulez on est parti de l'élan de la
manif pour tous la manif pour tout ça a
été un élan citoyen formidable qui a
provoqué un réveil des constants un
réveil pardon des consciences mais aussi
un réveil de l' envie d'engagement d'un
certain nombre de jeunes d'authenticité
de volonté ce désir ne pas rester assis
sur le bord en regardant en restant
spectateurs des choses et donc cette
nouvelle génération qui se lève est pas
prête de se rasseoir un tas dans vie
notamment celle de remettre vraiment
l'homme au coeur du système et le
système à la mesure de l'homme et pas l
inverse c'est à dire que sur tout un tas
de sujets c'est vrai bien sûr sur les
sujets sociétaux sur la question du
mariage pour tous mais c'est vrai aussi
dans tout un tas d'autres domaines je
peux en citer quelques-uns comme
l'économie l'entreprise
les questions d'immigration les
questions d'intégration qui sont
intimement liés toutes ces questions là
la question du social du logement qui
sont des vraiment des enjeux prégnant
dans la vie de nos concitoyens sens
commun a vocation à animer le débat
d'idées au sein de l'ump et a donné la
parole à des jeunes qui n'avaient pas
d'engagement politique avant de se
lancer puisque sens commun c'est à peu
près 80% de primo adhérents à
l'intérieur de l'ump et sur le fond sur
les idées on trouve aussi cette volonté
de réécrire la loi taubira par exemple
des choses que vous aimeriez voir
apparaître dans le programme dès 2017
ouais alors 2017 ou plus loin je crois
qu'il faut pas s'enfermer sur un sur un
timing forcément trop serré vous savez
quand on décide de partir sur la lune il
ya des étapes intermédiaires il ya ce
qu'on a appelé à gauche l'effet cliquet
qui a très bien marché avec des des des
courants comme europe ecologie les verts
c'est un peu cette ambition qui a un
sens commun au sein de l'ump c'est de
faire progresser ses idées sur le débat
sur le fond henri ensemençant la vie
politique de nos idées parce que en fait
le constat d'échec qu'on fait et on en
parle on emporte aussi notre part comme
membre de l'ump c'est que depuis trente
ans la droite un peu déserté le terrain
des idées et à l'essai sur des pans
entiers de l'économie sur l'école par
exemple sur la question de la culture
la gauche s'emparer de ces sujets là en
faisant croire et en racontant à
longueur de journée qu'ils étaient le
progrès tant et si bien que les français
ont fini par l'assimilé et
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de ré
expliquer aux français de ré expliquer
aussi à notre famille politique que les
idées droite non c'est pas ringard on a
un vrai projet justement par exemple
c'est quoi les idées de droite sur la
culture sur l'éducation sur les sujets
que vous abordez quelles sont les
priorités même si vous voulez pas vous
enfermer dans 2017 c'est la prochaine
échéance la capitale pour pour l'ump
même si vous voulez pas vous enfermez
quelles sont les idées que vous
souhaitez voir défendu alors je le dire
pour vous mais à la réécriture de la loi
taubira et puis la question aussi de la
surveillance en tout cas de ce projet de
fin de vie qui préparait actuellement
par le gouvernement que vous dénoncez
comme une euthanasie légaliser déguisée
en homme déguisé mais au-delà de ça au
delà c'est problématique là quels sont
les autres points précis ça repose
d'abord sur une valeur clair qui est
celle de la confiance par exemple sens
commun a pris position il ya quelques
jours après l'élection du enfin après le
deuxième tour on l'avait dit quelques
quelques jours avant le résultat de
l'élection nous on n'est pas par exemple
pour les consignes de vote on estime que
les électeurs sont suffisamment grand et
intelligent pour voter en conscience
dont le front national oui exactement
c'est le parti socialiste le propaq les
appareils aient vocation à donner des
comment dire des consignes de vote tous
ces si mes propriétaires des gens qui
ont voté pour eux les gens ont la
possibilité de faire un choix en
conscience de réfléchir très sereinement
aux choix politiques qui les engage ça
c'est des valeurs qui peuvent se
décliner sur des tas d'autres domaines
par exemple si on réfléchit en termes
d'économie c'est faire le choix de la
responsabilité
essayer de faire en sorte que chaque
personne ait la possibilité de vivre
décemment de son travail alors je sais
qu'aujourd'hui ça peut paraître un peu
provocant parce qu'on a une société qui
a beaucoup de chômage où beaucoup de
gens voudraient travailler ne peuvent
pas trouver un emploi mais si vous
voulez on voit là c'est des choses qu'on
va essayer de décliner comme ça
patiemment ça fait un an qu'on existe
donc toutes les propositions sont pas
encore sur la table on a un groupe 1 ce
qu'on appelle un pôle de réflexion qui
travaille avec des experts sur ces
questions là on a vocation à avancer ça
peut être aussi sur la sécurité dans les
prisons ça peut être sur la réinsertion
voilà je vous surprendrai pas en vous
disant que notre position est quand même
diamétralement opposée à celle de madame
taubira une fois encore sur la question
des peines alternatives à
l'emprisonnement bon ça se décline dans
les yvelines pour conclure concrètement
votre mouvement ça se passe ça passe par
des réunions il y en a une la semaine
dernière déjà ouais c'est surtout un
mouvement très très local ancré dans les
régions notre président et et nantais il
est issu du grand ouest de la france
pour nous c'est symbolique mais c'est
pas seulement symbolique dans les
yvelines ça se traduit par de nombreuses
réunions d'appartement c'est vraiment un
travail de fourmi pour nous de
développer sens commun et la force de
notre mouvement c'est qu'il part de la
base s'est pas uniquement un mouvement
parisiano parisiano pardon centre est
donc ce développement par petites
touches par petites réunions
d'appartement qui réunissent rarement
plus d'une vingtaine de personnes ce qui
nous mobilise d'ailleurs de nombreuses
soirées je veux remercier tous ceux qui
nous accueille voilà on se développe
vraiment comme ça de petites réunions au
petit réunion en présentant notre
mouvement nos ambitions très modeste
notre envie de changer les choses
généralement ça touche le coeur des gens
ça les intéresse et ils ont envie d'y
prendre part on a fait ainsi depuis
depuis un an et demi en décembre 2014 on
était à peu près à 80 réunions dans les
yvelines et clôturée par cette belle
réunion pour lancer l'année 2015 qui a
vu se réunir plus de 200 personnes à
bois d'arcy la semaine dernière c'est
vraiment voilà un grand remerciement je
voudrais adresser à tous nos bénévoles
tous nos responsables de ville qui donne
énormément de leur temps pour développer
notre mouvement et ça existait donc ce
mouvement sens commun notamment dans les
yvelines merci serre ils font vite vous
êtes le le responsable d'ong appartement
ou de sens commun nous parlons à présent
des élections départementales dans ce
set 8 politique avec la candidature du
président de la caisse qui de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin michel laugier le maire de
montigny se présente sur son canton au
canton qui comporte également la ville
guyancourt dont le maire est tout
simplement le conseiller général sortant
le socialiste françois de ligne et un
combat qui sera particulièrement si vide
par les fonctions occupées par les deux
hommes et qui ressemblera fortement un
troisième ronde après les dernières
municipales et puis sur le canton de
trappes cette fois ci les candidats de
la gauche se veulent à rassembler cela
concerne aussi les communes des longs
cours de la verrière alain ajaj maire
communiste de la verrière jeanine marie
première adjointe divers gauche de la
mairie de trappes la conseillère
générale sortante ont décidé de faire
équipe une union sans doute pour éviter
une déconvenue de la gauche face à la
droite représentée par jean michel
fourgous le maire ump d'elancourt
premier vice-président de 55 scrutin de
mars toujours le front national qui sera
bien présent dans les 21 cantons c'était
annoncé que 2 contre le département des
yvelines son responsable philippe
chevrier ne cache pas ses ambitions il
veut tout simplement faire du front
national le premier parti des yvelines
il n'y a actuellement aucun conseiller
autistes dans les yvelines les listes et
déposer binôme hommes femmes viennent
d'être tout juste présenté en préfecture
c est au micro de catherine du gâteau
que l'on retrouve philippe chevrier très
sérieusement nous voulons gagner le
département nous sommes scandalisés par
la manière dont ce dans ce département
est dirigée par quelqu'un qui n'est rien
d'autre qu'un repris de justice comment
se fait-il comment se fait-il qu'il a
récupéré la direction du département
alors avec la complicité des différents
élus de l'ump c'est un véritable
scandale nous allons le dénoncer bien
entendu et nous voulons remplacer cette
équipe les axes de campagne vous savez
on est on a on a été dans les conseils
municipaux depuis un petit moment on a
vu assez rapidement le désastre
financier de certaines villes et la
manière dont soit disant de dd des
députés ump qui se targuait d'être des
économistes gérée d'une manière
désastreuse des finances de l'homme de
leur mairie donc ces gens là on les
retrouve
conseil général rétablir une certaine
justice sociale dans la gestion de ce
département tout en ayant des finances
équilibrées
invités à présent du 7-8 politique henri
pailleux maire divers-droite encartés
ump de coignières depuis à 19 cents à 86
prévus en mars dernier avec plus de 60
56 pardon pour cent des voix bonsoir je
vous aviez prévenu que ce serait sans
doute votre dernier mandat mais pour
autant l'annnonce de votre démission a
surpris tout le monde au début de ce
mois de février c'était lors de votre
cérémonie de voeux vous avez motivé
votre départ par deux raisons tout
d'abord l'abandon du prolongement de
l'autoroute a12 dans le schéma directeur
de la région ile de france c'était l'an
dernier ça devait permettre de
désengorger la nationale 10 65 mille
véhicules traversent votre commune et
puis il ya aussi le dossier de
l'intercommunalité sans vais revenir
juste après déjà sur le prolongement de
de la douze c'est aussi votre démission
une démission de contestation c'est
comme ça qu'il faut l'apercevoir non je
dois dire que j'ai pris la décision de
fois disons de démissionner de mon poste
en décembre dernier alors bien
évidemment les deux sujets que vous avez
évoqué son majeur dans la décision est
prise mais ça va bien au delà
j'avoue que je vive dans un pays que je
ne comprends plus alors pour préciser
les choses j'ai été je suis rentré au
conseil municipal de coignières en mars
83 j'ai été élu maire 86 ça fait donc
près de trente ans je suis aux affaires
sur coignières mais je me suis engagé en
politique à 18 en 1958 avec le retour du
général de gaulle ce qui signifie que je
suis gaulliste et profondément gaulliste
et aujourd'hui dans la france telle
qu'elle évolue je ne me reconnais pas
dans mes valeurs et donc j'ai décidé en
décembre que je n'acceptais plus de
servir de caution je dirais dans un
système qui ne va pas du tout la
question de l'autoroute juste pour
revenir aussi sur l'intercommunalité on
vous a déjà entendu à ce sujet sur sur
cette antenne mais là aussi rejoindre
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
impensable et ça va au delà de vos
convictions et vous ne pouvez pas passer
au delà de ce problème la question 1er
janvier de rejoindre 50 anglicane dans
mes côtés pour faire court il faut
savoir que nous sommes sortis en 84 de
la ville nouvelle et à l'époque caso de
ferme avait imposé le 2 pays une
participante financière extrêmement
élevé à la vie de nouvelles d'une part
et de ses 25 hectares du terrain des
bécanes à la vue de la verrière bon et
puis aujourd'hui eh bien on nous remet
envie de nouvelles et là il rêve de
choses que je ne comprends pas il sait
quelque chose qui m'est totalement
insupportable
nous ne voulons pas coignières à les
envies de nouvelles j'ai sollicité les
connais rien par une élection organisée
comme une élection municipale et là
dessus les connais à sont prononcés à 98
5% pour conserver la communauté de vues
des temps
et donc je ne comprends pas ce qui se
passe je comprends pas l'accélération je
dirais que veut le gouvernement ou le
préfet de région en la matière ça
m'échappe totalement et à partir de là
également ce que je dénonce c'est
l'opacité dans laquelle tout cela se met
en place parce que la crct la commission
régionale qui décide de tout cela sur
proposition du préfet de région eh bien
je ne l a été paraît-il élu par des
représentants des ces dci et moi
personnellement j'ai jamais élu
personnes en cdi dont on m'a viré parce
que j appartenait avant les élections
estivales donc long pour vous c'est une
illustration aujourd'hui de cette
politique vous disiez à travers laquelle
vous ne vous reconnaissez pas le monde
politique tel qu'il fonctionne je ne
reconnais pas on est dans un monde plus
il ya plus de morale il ya plus
d'éthique le sait
l'intérêt particulier qui prend le pas
sur l'intérêt général et donc moi je
suis désolé mais j'ai pas été élevé
comme ça ni pas mieux ni par les parents
ni parmi les négateurs c'est le désabusé
aujourd'hui de la politique je suis
totalement désabusé de politique je
reste néanmoins à l'ump n'avaient pas à
rendre complètement votre carte quitter
le monde de la politique avec votre
démarche devrait se situer entre mars et
avril je suis un fidèle de 1058 donc
j'étais à lui les nerfs étaient à lui
dire j'étais au rpr aujourd'hui je suis
à l'ump je suis pas des gens qui devant
les caméras déchirent leur carte de
membre
excusez moi pour faire du cinéma quoi
non non je vais garder ben mondiale
quand l'ump d'abord parce que j'estime
qu'il faut est engagé dans la vie et
là-dessus excusez moi mais si je regarde
l'ensemble de tous les partis existants
en france je ne le reconnais nulle pa
donc je vais là où je reprenais le mieux
encore une fois l'ump même si ma foi le
gaullisme à l'ump ma fille on peut en
discuter et lyon ou en main ce parcours
cette conviction vous avez décidé d'en
parler également dans un ouvrage la
force de la conviction amer et ses
combats ses sauts aux éditions de
l'archipel et vous l'avez en main
justement est cet ouvrage vous êtes en
dédicace actuellement jusqu'à la fin de
la semaine à la maison du voisinage dans
votre commune c'est disponible également
en librairie vous le disiez vous avez
débuté très jeune en politique 18 ans du
butin la motivation pour vous engager à
cet âge là à passer le tout simplement
parce que jeter dans une
dans une famille il était un gaulliste
d'une part et puis d'autre part je suis
ainsi fait que je me suis très
rapidement engagé dans tout un tas de
choses et le retour du général m'a
frappé et de ce fait est bien je me suis
immédiatement gagés est d'ailleurs à
l'époque j'étais le plus jeune encartés
de l'umr
et de michèle et michel debré qui était
à l'époque communiste m'avait pris sous
son aile protectrice d'ailleurs et mais
comme je fais dix mille choses n'avaient
pas terminé mes études
donc je ne me suis véritablement engagée
à cogner dans la politique et au conseil
général par la suite que assez
tardivement il faut dire c'est à dire
vous n'aviez pas l'ambition faire
carrière en politique je n'ai jamais eu
l'ambition de faire carrière en
politique
d'ailleurs je suis devenu maire de
connaître tout à fait par hasard je ne
voulais pas je suis devenu ensuite
conseiller général des yvelines tout à
fait par hasard gérard larcher mais d'en
convoquer le en 93 dans son bureau à
20h30 le 24 décembre deux heures avant
le réveillon j'avais parfois il me
demandait de venir le voir et tout de go
il me dit que ça y est j'ai décidé c'est
toi qui vas aller au champ d'honneur
voilà et ce n'est que pour lui faire
plaisir et j étais en me disant au genre
de boulot et les deux sortants sont
réélus que je serais battu mais comme
j'ai dit que comme j'aime les campagnes
voulait lui faire précieux je lui dis
oui et alors elle j'ai été élu et et
vous êtes connu pour votre franc-parler
pas de langue de bois avec vous quitte
parfois aussi à faire perdre votre
famille politique le canton coignard on
parlait justement des départementales
que vous avez réussi à remporter la face
aux représentants de la gauche de
l'époque qui était maire de de maurepas
georges mougeot ensuite en 2008 il ait
eu un nouveau scrutin il ya 2000 ans et
puis c'est ce dernier scrutin où il y a
eu cette candidature de l'ump qui était
qui a été donnée porter l'investiture à
gérald favier première à nyon n'ont pas
dû au maire d'elancourt nous écoutait
pas du tout le comité départemental du
mpf a donné l'investiture pas 485 voix
sur 14 95 de votants est là dessus donc
jean-michel for us qui est un
le maire d'elancourt eh bien je dirais à
décider et je n'ai jamais compris
pourquoi parce que moi je les ai
toujours soutenu a décidé de présenter
en évidence son premier adjoint contre
moi et entre les deux temps vous avez
maintenu votre candidature et de
candidatures à droite je les avais
prévenus dès le départ j'étais vice
président du conseil général sortant
d'une part et d'autre part et bien
j'avais fait le score que je viens de
dire au comité départemental et donc
j'estime et que monsieur favier devait
se retirer d'ailleurs c'est même pas
familier qui menait la campagne c'était
fou rousski d'amener il a fait appel au
national pour essayer d'invalider en
avait six heures départemental le
pandraud qui s'occupe de la commission
des conflits
c'était oui c'était à l'ump à l'époque
et bien débouté fond rouge chef allié et
ils les ont exclus
vous n'avez pas de regret qu'il ya eu
ces tensions au sein de votre famille
politique ou d'avoir d'avoir autant pesé
pour fait au final de ne pas faire de
langue de bois quelques fois en
politique est-ce qu'il faut pas en faire
la langue de moi n'ont
donc jamais non jamais il n'avait aucun
regret surtout de ses années en
politique
le seul regret que je peux peut-être
avoir c'est que j'aurais pu faire une
autre carrière politique que si
en
1958 60-65 on va dire eh bien je m'étais
franchement engagé parce que je
connaissais tout le monde au sein de
l'umr à l'époque et j'étais très
introduit mais comme je faisais d'autres
montagnes comme choisi de l'aviron comme
je n'avais pas terminé mes études
j'avais mon service militaire à fleurs
fruits et beaucoup de choses à faire
encore
donc
non j'étais un bon militant de base je
collais j'affichais je distribuais je
faisais les boîtes aux lettres et puis
voilà et ça me suffisait à mon bonheur
vous n'aimez pas qu'on dise de vous
c'est exact un animal politique
personnage atypique en paie pas dur je
sois un animal politique non non non
mouchon portel vous êtes en tout cas un
personnage atypique vous êtes aussi un
homme de la nuit vous travailler la nuit
vous coucher à 8 heures du matin depuis
1958 je ne me suis jamais couché avant 7
heures du matin et pourquoi pourquoi
travailler la nuit vous êtes plus
inspiré la nuit tranquille donc c'est
comme ça j'étais un horrible chahuteurs
quand j'étais en pension chez les
jésuites et j'ai chahuté toute la nuit
donc je dormais pas du tout et jamais
quitté on peut le dire même si
effectivement pour le coup c'est pas
politiquement correct mais pour
travailler la nuit ses cigares ah oui
oui je fume
14h08 14 6 heures par nuit
et puis avant de me coucher je peux
prendre un petit verre de cognac pour
maintenir la chanter et vous allez
continuer sur ce rythme là même une fois
que vous serez plus maire de bruit oui
absolument parce que j'ai cette activité
je travaille au sein de la société
française d'énergie nucléaire d'une part
je suis bonapartiste en plus d'être
gaullistes et donc je travaillais la
fondation napoléon et
au souvenir de polygones eurent parlé
tout à l'heure de votre déception envers
la politique vous êtes désabusé
aujourd'hui de voir comment les choses
évoluent est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment de pouvoir encore peser
d'inverser à votre échelle un petit peu
les choses même sur le secteur quel
message vous passerez par exemple à
votre successeur au sein du conseil
municipal non je ne rêve pas je me
retire et lorsqu'on sait très bien qu'un
homme politique se retire très
rapidement nous dit maintenant bien
évidemment j'ai tout un tas d'amis dans
le département que ce soit permis et 10
et franck borotra gérard larcher il en
passe de temps que je ne serai pas je
pense totalement oublié mais je n'ai pas
a priori l'intention g20 75 ans
également donc avec la vie de patachon
que j'ai pu mener toute ma vie pas ça
commence à peser aussi et donc voilà
donc je continuerai bien évidemment à
suivre activement ce qui se passe si je
peux mettre mon grain de sel quelque
part je ne manquerai pas de le faire et
en particulier je n'ai toujours pas à
vendre et on dit et à 12 et vont l'idée
de la terre vitalité
actuellement des mouvements qui naissent
dans le sud de la france contre
l'intercommunalité à montpellier en
pratique de biais et je compte bien je
dirais me rapprocher d'eux pour voir
étudier si éventuellement on peut faire
quelque chose juste un mot pour rebondir
vous avez évoqué l'oubli l'oubli ça ne
vous fait pas peur qu'on vous oublie
qu'on oublie un homme politique on le
sait pour les hommes politiques qui ont
consacré de nombreuses années c'est
difficile quelquefois de tourner la page
des zircons et plus hommes politiques
c'est vrai que j'en ai fait une première
expérience sur le court terme parce que
lorsque j'ai annoncé ma démission ou à
mes voeux le 30 janvier et bien pendant
trois jours j'étais un peu à plat je
dirais un peu épuisé alors je sais pas
si c'est le contrecoup tout cela je n'en
sais rien du tout enfin voir en tous les
cas maintenant ça va bien et puis là
dessus pas lui reprendre du poil de la
bête et puis je vais repartir au combat
là où j'aurai un combat mais cette
commune de coignières j'espère pour
conclure vous y avez consacré 30 ans 30
ans en tant que maire il ya longtemps
que je n'ai plus de 30 ans effectivement
quelle image vous voulez laisser vous
aimeriez en tout cas que les habitants
retiennent je veux dire est que les
habitants même bien changé d'ailleurs
parce qu'il faut quand même savoir que
paul hier est une ville qui votent
socialistes aux élections nationales
près de 60% et ils m'ont largement réélu
aux cantonales à plus de 70% et
également aux municipales je suis
toujours passé où la main quoi et donc
justement il vous aime bien mais quelle
image vous voulez leur laisser quel
dossier sur lequel vous êtes le/la prix
satisfait à l'écouté j'ai fait une
plaquette je dirais pour faire le bilan
de tout ce que j'ai fait en 30 ans qui
est une très très belle plaquette
qu'elle distribue à tout les connais
rien bah écoutes je leur laisse je
dirais ce petit ouvrage tout seul dit
prête à soutenir si pour ceux qui
veulent la conserver et puis pour ceux
qui veulent en savoir encore plus sur
votre parcours il ya donc cet ouvrage
aux éditions de l'archipel la force de
la conviction voilà le combat d'un maire
henri paye merci mr de coignières pour
encore quelques mois ce sera avril mars
c'est décidé non non je suis pas contre
du budget merci à vous en tout cas c'est
la fin de ce set 8 politique prochaine
émission le 24 février et puis je vous
retrouve à chaque soir 18h à 19h et
22h30 pour le journal d'information
locale